I once was doing an article when I was
working in Fortune magazine I did an
article about power i actually did two
wonderful about power and corporations
and I got very interested in
psychological testing and how and
because there was a fad this was i can't
remember seven or eight years ago there
was a fad for giving psychological tests
to people before they got promoted that
myers-briggs tests but also other kinds
of tests I also was intrigued because
back in the 1950s there was a fad for
aptitude tests and in fact it was
concerned with the aptitude test fads
that got william h white to start
writing the book that became the
organization man or the articles for
fortunate became an organization that
and included in that book is a chapter
on how to cheat on aptitude tests how to
take them out a cheat on so i got
interested in the personality tests and
i went to a psychologist friend and i
said would you teach me how to cheat on
psychology test she said no I can't I
mean I'm not allowed you know
professional standards it would I can't
but i'll give you one i'll give you the
battery that i give because she does
executive coaching and so on so so so
she gave me this battery test and gave
me the feedback and out of it of course
i tried to chief but but out of it i got
some interesting feedback in which she
said that she was intrigued by the way
my mind worked because she found that
that my mind worked in a way that not
too many other people in her experience
experienced it did which is it made all
kinds of connections to things in
strange ways I would you know I leap
from A to Z 2 m to l to pee and I pull
in things from from a whole lot of a
whole lot of sources and sort of danced
around topics until I get it right if I
get passionate about an idea I swarm it
you know I I overdo it I kill it you
know i mean i just go all over it until
I think I understand it or until it or
until i'm bored and I go somewhere else
so it's that kind of there's not an
orderly process it's a fairly physical
process I mean there's a squirming a lot
around in my chair when I'm excited by
an idea or I start talking people I I
want I want to run it by them so so it's
a kind of a noisy a noisy process of
seeing connections and getting excited
by them